أعضاء عائلات الفضاء ليسوا بآلاف الآلاف
الجرحى وناتشي تيحال ليسا من سكان إيزم
الجنوب الذي يعيش لسنوات عديدة ليس بالأمر السهل
المواطنون الإسرائيليون ليسوا كذلك
أنا ومازيم، السيد رئيس الوزراء، لسنا كذلك
يا إلهي، لن نسمح بوضع تفوز فيه حماس هنا
نسمع تهديدا بجلوس بن جفير
يقول زعيم حزبك ما إذا كانت الصفقة جيدة
نحن لسنا هناك بهذه الطريقة، لذا فإن السؤال هو، لماذا يجب أن أنظر؟
نحن لا نهدد بهذا كتهديد، لا يوجد شيء
أننا نريد أكثر من رؤية المختطفين مرة أخرى
المنزل ليس ايو ما هو ثمن العودة
المختطفون ثمن إعادة المختطفين
وهو وقف هذا القتال إذا كان القتال كوخاً
لشهرين
الحرب وسأقول أنني أعرف كيف أستعد في هذين الشهرين
من الأفضل ألا يكلفني المزيد من القتل
وبعد ذلك يمكنني إكمال المهمة
طالما تريد ولكن ليس وقف القتال
إنها الصفقة إذا أردناهم على قيد الحياة أم لا
دعنا نقول دعهم يموتوا دعهم يموتون هناك حتى
والأخير بفضلهم بنينا دولة إسرائيل على دمائهم
لم يطلبوا ذلك، ولم يرغبوا في ذلك
هؤلاء الأبطال، لكننا قررنا كمجتمع إسرائيلي
هذا أو هؤلاء الستة عشر ومرة ​​أخرى أعتقد أنه ضروري
أدخل وافعل قدر الإمكان لحفظها
لكن علينا أن نضع آلاف المدنيين أمامهم
الإسرائيليون الآخرون الذين سيموتون الآن هي المشكلة
عساف يحترق الآن، المشكلة قادمة
تم أخذ 136 شخصًا من منازلهم
من حفلة أُخذوا من مكان لم يقصدوه على الإطلاق
يجدون أنفسهم في غزة في نهاية المطاف، دولة إسرائيل
كان ينبغي تجنب الاستهلاك في أكتوبر
نحن الآن نفتح التفاصيل الجديدة حول الصفقة
المختطفون ومطلب حماس مطلبهم الرئيسي
لإطلاق سراح الإرهابيين المتورطين في هذه الصفقة
سليمان مسو دعاتة ينشر التفاصيل بشكل صحيح
على الرغم من أن ميشيل نافار ما زال لا يُرجع إجابة
رسميًا، ولكن تم بالفعل طرح المطالب الرئيسية خلال الدورة
الأيام القليلة الماضية وأحد المتطلبات هو بالضبط ما
أنت تقول الآن ونحن ننشر الليلة
وتطالب حماس إسرائيل بالإفراج عن كل وحدة
نخبته هي ما نعرفه باسم نوفا
الذي شارك في المجموعة الصعبة في السابع من أكتوبر بحسب
المعلمون في التفاوض يحتويون على هذا الطلب
بالفعل خلال القمة التي عقدت في باريس من قبل قطر أيضا
وأيضا في مصر ومرة ​​أخرى خلال المحادثات بين التوترات
بالمناسبة، في الأيام القليلة الماضية، يمكنني أن أخبرك بذلك أيضًا
خلال النهار عندما يكون إسماعيل أنيا في القاهرة
وإدارة الرحلة إلى هناك وتقديم ما نستطيع
لنقول الآن عن موقف إسرائيل ميكال أنهم موجودون
مناقشات ولكن لم يتم اتخاذ قرار بعد في هذا الصدد
هذا هو إطلاق نوفا وكما قلت نحن
في الساعات الدرامية، من المفترض أن يقدم سنوار إجابة
إلى إسرائيل عبر هذه القاطرة يتأخر السنوار الذي يجلس
الآن في المخبأ يراقبك ويشاهد تجربته اليوم
يجلس في مخبأه يشاهد التلفاز
في الإسرائيلي يقول لنفسه، أوتوتو، أنا قادم
في المقابل، تعود الشركة الإسرائيلية إلى القتال
جميع القراءات تنهار الآن بأي ثمن
إن وقف الحرب هو الظل الذي يحرر حشوتهم
أكثر من ذلك بقليل، أكثر من ذلك بقليل
أنفاس وأفوز
النجاة من البلد الذي تعرفه ربما قبل السبعة
أكتوبر هي الدولة ذات أعلى قيمة مشفرة
الذي عقد فيه فداء لأسابيع، هذا هو البلد الذي أنت فيه
أريد أن أرى كيف تسير الأمور الآن
بالتأكيد نعم، هذه هي القيمة التي تظهر في كتابك
لدينا أنا
أعتقد أنه ينبغي أن يوضع في الاعتبار
وقبل كل شيء، من ناحية أخرى، الوزراء في الحكومة يشغلون كل شيء
ضغط الوقت ضد الصفقة وكل شيء يبدو فظيعًا
شابير أود الاتصال بالسيد نتنياهو
من فضلك السيد
نتنياهو للمتظاهرين
المتظاهرون
عند مدخل كريم شالوم، ستعرف فقط
أنه إذا لم يكن هناك العرض
حماس ليس لديها إمدادات غذائية
لأسابيع آنا منك تفعل أي شيء
في قدرتك